[Music]
[Applause]
how's it going bros my name is pierre
bad welcome back to ask in coffee bread
they're good
holy [ __ ] i saved in a bad spot why is
it not working that I'm playing with a
mouse but my jacket
check plays I'm not
I'm so bad that oh god oh god oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah I forgot I can turn
off the mouse hide cursor all right I
know some people who are bitching about
it stop tapping out alright there we go
good job hey I'm alive holy [ __ ]
all right as you may or may not notice
I'm playing with the mouse that's what
she said
Oh hilarious but the only bad thing
about it is that you turn like a [ __ ]
but you do that and with the rhythm we
mode anyway so I figured this is the
best way it's just how it is you see how
long I'm playing right and I might be
darker what the heck is going on I'm
making babies wait could I go in jail
for saying that
come on baby I'm a rape yeah my name is
Miki I'm a rape yeah I'm gonna rape you
I mean by I'm curious I think oh god
people yeah
oh god he has a lot of people care I
mean for that kind of stuff that's good
that's good
come here girl girl we care oh she likes
play games ha ha all right all right
should I round like a [ __ ] hey
it's not working too bad I mean this
works for me it's better than the
[ __ ] Wii mode going on like ok ok
girl
it's time I'm not into Katie's I'm sorry
ok hey hey come back here sir but I turn
around
scribble fragment ok I have the scribble
fragment I have to give a fragment I
have a scribble fragment alright let's
just go these guys are done with this
place freaking hospital
I hate to burn at hospitals and never do
anything good for you they just [ __ ] you
up like every single game out there
that's a [ __ ] hospital in it it's not
good I'll tell you it's not good
Zakhar for anyone hey what's going on
that naked baby come back and make it
baby I sped all the divide the screen
because I was naked babies hey I should
pick up that flashlight can i rounding
out of energy don't wanna write it's
such a what was that I was gonna say
it's such a pain in the ass that you run
at it all right I'm just gonna pick this
up that's what I'm talking about spare
battery okay all right let's just go
I don't even care anymore I got a really
dark voice all decided doctor we're
supposed to do something about my voice
but they [ __ ] it up
my name is Miki I have this voice all
right let's go
Oh Oh No ah ah ah
visibly this of it sounds but the [ __ ]
damn belated his [ __ ] it up oh god I
just doing that it's so annoying is it
done I'd be cool wow that was just
obnoxious president she doesn't want me
to go there oh god the sound I'm gonna
have to mute that [ __ ] emulator why
don't they just [ __ ] worry it's so
annoying I can't go here what
Oh God
[Music]
again now again call
I have no effect the safe stay
safes they bra got it alive my fake
sneeze so use it up or down up or down
up or down I see Dan just because I've
seen not very good
well look look okay okay okay
I'm just gonna go down here what Mickey
stranded come on Mickey
god [ __ ] damn please am i late that
that sound this is too much
oh [ __ ] man I can't play with these
[ __ ] I'm gonna edit out for you bros
but it's pretty [ __ ] bad I'm like a
lie how long doesn't want me to go can I
go here oh god this map is huge Oh Oh
bro no no no no no I'm not into that I'm
not into that no pubic hair under wash
not into peer we care
fine let's do number one okay let's go
Erica Mika Miki whatever your name is
go bro
got bro bro bro all right bro here's X
it's perfect
super girl you're gonna actually if this
game makes me go up all those stairs
again
Oh bro I'm just gonna say I hope Rossum
huh oh come on how strong his hair
anyway oh man keep going
it's fine because you know you have
flashlights and [ __ ] so huh I see it
it's down in the basement girl no boy
girl I don't know if Nikki's girl a boy
named let's go to b-1b [ __ ] one I get
the feeling I should have walked up
first
uh-uh
okay this go make it sealing me buddy
it's you and me buddy
it's always been just me you and me but
whatever all right come on Miki you can
do it if not do it for me do it for your
penis think about your penis I mean it's
been there for you all this time all
right this better [ __ ] work
you store better work come on one door
that works please yay all right
[Music]
out of here cool all over here forget as
you should ask all that [ __ ] and that
[ __ ] emulator
this is dumb thisa I'm happy now I'm gay
I just wanna shake what's over here bad
huh Oh bro bro rap
now brow that's not good for anyone
right all right we're back in this
vagina hole full of hair oh my god this
is I don't even know anymore all right
freaking jungle uh maybe is afraid over
the height yes come on get my light
buddy eat my light right I heard the
footsteps why I don't rush this place no
no no no no here comes your bad part
again I got no problem I never had a
problem my entire life
oh yeah you better you better go I'm
going out of here
that's them more Galoob I mean goo all
right mark goo let's go to more goo oh
there's gonna be bad yeah
that obtaining that those sounds that I
don't Oh God
oh it's morgue oh [ __ ] oh oh
no she's totally in there oh god I was
gonna go No Oh actually could go
I never thought all right again we don't
have to check out her course
sad truth is I think I have to oh god oh
god not this again
maybe she's pissed now she's like why do
you ignore my cops why
ah the hair is gone that's me I don't
really like hair son oh my you taking
rock that it that is I already got what
I got it's shaking price good cuz i'm
what is that my so an item that i want
you know i didn't know it was blinking
to me is like take me take me now yeah
yes yes let's get out of here hey
geez i love kiss i mean give me the key
oh rooftop key oh yeah they best be
joking
we are not seriously going back to the
roof no oh
flashlight I love flashlight - look how
they did it I mean it's way past bedtime
why am i doing here let's just pick off
the flashlight never got the spare
battery I would do it we love those
[ __ ] flashlight and be like come on
[ __ ] what what you got what you got no
you got you know I got you don't we did
that stop committing your your dog [ __ ]
no I didn't all right you gotta say like
oh you don't got [ __ ] all right
something like that okay let's go
this is go okay
hello okay let's just go back and this
got a roof top just powder love tap I
might edit this out part out cuz it'll
take me probably like five minutes you
got a roof top only and I want to see
how this ends right no just ignore the
hair on the wall that's normal that is
all the time of me yesterday yep
yes computer Karen the loss huh what's
there but I see you okay okay
I hope the battery will last me key is
not in a hurry now whatever I have a lot
of time doesn't matter I'll take my time
or she's a Hannah yet oh I totally mood
by itself huh now now I'm stuck now
please move please Moe know if I can if
I can move this out over the way I'm
gonna be seriously pissed I want to go
to the rooftop I need to get a roof dad
I saw you
there's got to be a way to move this
stop I hear you walking out there don't
don't try to deny the fact that you're
walking out are you kidding me I'm so
handicapped that I can't even move this
oh yes good job
no no no no I don't how about the game
where did the game go why did the
[ __ ] game Wow
the game just disappeared okay all right
we're back for the third time I don't
know what I have in the game just
disappear though oh no she's not totally
there
all right now just room no she's not
she's gonna rape me with that fury care
okay
dynamo up okay good good no gotta fire
up by your thumbs up come on Mickey
me got it's time to go buddy yes Trish
oh good we're good I never had white
boxes now I'm not now please let out
whatever I did I got me ah ah this is
[ __ ] me up I can't take this [ __ ]
sound if anyone knows
what is that which is nice that sound
like something is touching their vagina
and really weird way oh god oh no oh
it's in their roof oh no of course that
[ __ ] thing is gonna start again
ah no now don't ruin it for me it's not
a penis Jesus Christ I don't appreciate
penises from the roof especially long
and black ones ok i fite the penis
ok I'm finding the penis come here found
my fantasy you [ __ ]
doesn't sing with the penis oh yeah
bring your penis you better bring it
laughs no problem huh
bring it bring it bring it come on penis
somewhere - got peanut lumpiness
show me your move can I make it laughs
no problem I mean right I don't [ __ ]
every day penis I fried with penises
every day I got this no problem
this is [ __ ]
alright I'm gonna end it here both this
if anyone knows where there's a sound in
this [ __ ] game please let me know
because I might have a heart attack so
anyway that's pretty much it hope you
enjoyed anyway I'm gonna edit out for
you bros you will still hear them all
though and that's pretty much it like a
favorite Nolan contra and I'll show you
tomorrow
[Music]
empty ran for me and I just click I
didn't want to jump is that out I miss
our bro